des photographies sur un avis de
recherche voici les seules images
connues de félicien kabuga
l'homme est accusé d'avoir joué un rôle
clé dans le génocide des tutsi au rwanda
c'était en 1994 l'odeur est
pestilentielle les corps en
décomposition de familles entières
bornes encore la route entre la
frontière tanzanienne et kigali
les a surpris dans leur maison d'autres
froidement exécuté les mains liées dans
le dos
félicien kabuga c'est d'abord un homme
d'affaires un proche du président
rwandais de l'époque juvénal habyarimana
le 6 avril le président est assassiné
c'est le début du génocide
les tutsis sont chassés et massacrés par
les interhamwe les extrémistes hutus
félicien kabuga est accusé d'avoir
financé ses milices génocidaires
ils sont les nervis de ce qu'il reste du
gouvernement rwandais
john souvent très jeunes bien armé ou
simplement équipés de machette
ce sont eux qui sont responsables de la
plupart des massacres commis dans ce
pays depuis le 6 avril
félicien kabuga c'est aussi un acteur
majeur de l'appel au génocide
à l'image de cambourg à un magazine
extrémistes hutus qu'ils financent une
feuille extrémistes qui n'hésite pas à
mettre à la une
l'arme du crime la machette kangoo race
et l'avant-garde une kyrielle de titres
de presse qu'ils partagent tous le même
objectif
félicien kabuga dirige la radio
télévision des mille collines
sur les ondes le média de la n17 au
meurtre des tutsi le but propager
l'idéologie du hutu power un mouvement
extrémiste pro ou tout émettant depuis
kigali puis di segni la radio des
milices hutu déversait depuis trois mois
un flot de haine et de propagande sur
une population affolée et largement
analphabète
chaque jour le média divulguer les noms
de personnes à abattre les primes sont
offertes en échange de cadavres 24
heures sur 24
la radio appels aux massacres là où deux
oléoducs a rapporté l'apa le 17 juillet
1994 le génocide des tutsi prend fin
c'est le début de 26 ans de cavale pour
félicien kabuga le 16 mai 2020 il est
arrêté en france à asnières sur seine à
l'âge de 87 ans
[Musique]